i know you're super interested you spend
a lot of time thinking about side
hustles how people can earn incremental
income on top of their current job tell
me some of your best ideas there well we
have this i kind of have this belief of
our mantra contrarian thinking is
civilize the mind make savage the body
build the bank account and so the
thought is you know start wherever you
are um so if you can buy businesses now
to diversify awesome if all you can do
is start with a little side hustle to
add to your current income stream
awesome if all you have time for is just
to renegotiate your salary where you're
at in order to get more income awesome
but the goal is that we move towards
this sort of free human this financially
free human that can think for themselves
and act for themselves too that's the
whole sort of frame but um let me look i
i put some of them together but one of
the ones that i thought was fascinating
that i saw the other day so i don't know
if you guys have this in florida
actually in miami but i was in
california in san diego and all along
the beaches there are these little
pop-up picnics have you guys ever seen
that with like the umbrella and then
there's a little
stand and basically what they do is it
looks like a beautiful little instagram
worthy moment um but there are humans
who set up this picnic for you so if
you're gonna propose to somebody or take
somebody on a date there's like
champagne waiting and little fluffy
pillows and those silly umbrellas that
people want to use and i got curious and
so i went up to them and there were
these two guys and um and they were both
mexican immigrants and they were like
yeah we started this business on the
side one was an in architecting school
and one was um i don't know maybe
marketing and and they were like yeah we
started this business we now make seven
thousand dollars a month by putting
together a few pillows like a little
charcuterie board and a couple of
different umbrellas for people and we
set up three so they do three different
segments each day you can do morning
afternoon or evening and they charge
anywhere from 100 to 300 for the setup
and they rinse and repeat so it's their
weekend side hustle um and i love this
business because you don't need a lot of
overhead you don't really even need
permission people will immediately yell
like what about permits what about
insurance but i think in most businesses
like how many of your friends do you
know they're like i'm gonna start a
business so i went out and i got my
insurance to start the business today
like nobody does that it's like you
start where you are and this one i
thought was fascinating so now they make
you know whatever seven times 12 is a
year if i told you this weekend friday
afternoon you had to go make a thousand
dollars in cash by monday morning what
would you do do i have anything like any
we'll call it incremental income
basically you can use a couple dollars
to buy some goods or some tools that you
need uh but basically yeah you just got
to go earn a thousand dollars you can't
set up a structure you don't want to set
up something that's going to last it's
just as quick as you can a thousand
dollars oh yeah i mean i don't hate this
pop-up picnic idea i would basically the
first tenant would be pre-sale so i
would basically say i'm a pretty
convincing sales person so i think i
would probably go around on the internet
i'd do something for free like create a
free instagram account and basically
offer you know something could be a
pop-up picnic it could be
um it could be like a a cool dinner that
you set up for people but i would have
set up an experience because people are
craving experiences right now post
pandemic and if i wanted to i could make
definitely more than a thousand bucks by
just saying i would steal pictures from
other people's events like oh here's
cody sanchez picnics and i'd steal
pictures from other people's picnics so
i don't have any of the stuff i don't
have any money to buy the stuff but i
would put it out and i would target
towards people who were located in the
park before so you know how you can
check the geo targeting and instagram so
i'd go to like here i'd be like who is
it zilker park here's a bunch of people
that look like they were there recently
i'd probably ping 50 of them and say i
have this opening it's my last one it's
on saturday uh if you want to i could
set up this beautiful picnic for you
that mostly celebrities have including
some champagne maybe that part's free on
me it's very cheap 200
and i'd probably do that you know
seven times and by the end of the
weekend uh they would probably pre-pay
me for it so i'd have all the goods i'd
set it up and we'd be good to go and
then you'd probably upsell them into
something else like oh you're gonna
propose to your girlfriend do you want
this wine probably not that would look
really cheap man you should probably go
with this instead so maybe this is
recency bias but i like that idea